>> Bret: SOME SCHOOLS ARE NOT
WAITING FOR ANOTHER DISASTER TO
ACT.
MATT FINN SHOWS US THEY ARE
ALREADY GIVING THEIR TEACHERS
AND THE MEANS TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AND THEIR STUDENTS.
>> TWO SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEAR
DAYTON, OHIO, HAVE A
CONFIDENTIAL TEAM OF TEACHERS
AND STAFF TRAINED TO FIRE BACK
ON AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
>> TRAINED TO ADDRESS THE
THREAT, NOT TO RUN AWAY.
>> THE SCHOOLS TAKE MEASURES TO
CONCEAL THE GUNS THAT ARE HIDDEN
IN SAFES THAT CAN BE OPENED ONLY
BY STAFF.
EACH MEMBER IS VETTED BY THE
DISTRICT, MUST HAVE A LICENSE TO
CARRY AND ATTEND RIGOROUS
TRAINING.
>> THE TEAM MEMBERS HAVE ACCESS.
>> MANY STUDENTS SEEM TO SUPPORT
THE IDEA OF THEIR TEACHERS BEING
ARMED.
>> TO HAVE PEOPLE INSIDE THE
SCHOOL WHO KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
DOING AND WHO CAN PROTECT US, I
THINK THAT'S AMAZING.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY ROOM
FOR COMPLAINTS.
>> INSIDE THOSE FOUR WALLS, THEY
ARE OUR SAFETY.
>> BOTH DISTRICTS FACE
OPPOSITION.
>> LET THE TEACHERS TEACH.
>> THE POLICE CHIEF SAYS HE'S
NOT AGAINST ARMED TEACHERS BUT
WORRIES COULD INTERFERE WITH HIS
FIRST RESPONDERS.
>> ONE OR TWO PEOPLE WITH GUNS
TO SIX OR SEVEN PEOPLE WITH GUNS
WITHOUT HAVING ASSURANCE WITH A
GOOD GUY OR BAD GUY IS.
>> LEE SHELBY COUNTY SHERIFF
TELLS FOX NEWS HE DEVELOPED THE
PLAN WHILE WATCHING SANDY HOOK
UNFOLD KNOWING HIS GOAL WAS NOT
PREPARED.
>> WE CANNOT DEPEND ON THE STATE
OR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE CAN'T DEPEND ON PSYCHOLOGISTS
WE CAN'T DEPEND ON PSYCHOLOGIST
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
>> THE ARMED SECURITY GUARD SAYS
EACH STAFF MEMBER WENT THROUGH
INTENSE TRAINING AND HE
CONSIDERED THEM CERTIFIED
BACKUP.
>> A MINUTE IS A LONG TIME
SOMETIMES IN A SITUATION WHERE
YOU ARE DEALING WITH AN ACTIVE
KILLER.
>> AS A NATIONAL DEBATE RAGES ON
OVER WHETHER TEACHERS AND STAFF
SHOULD BE ARMED, THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN OHIO SAYS IT STANDS
BY ITS DECISION BECAUSE OF ONE